fresh after the entire anime community
had gotten over being wrapped up with
blue string boobs everyone was ready to
let Hestia go and allow a new fad to
take over
apparently this call was heard as this
hot summer season got invaded by the
devil itself
yes this summer the devil was summoned
from the underworld
this time incarnated in the form of a
fat snake beard we're boot wrapped in a
16 year old girl's body hematoma Rajan
told the story of a young girl
struggling with her severe coke
addiction spreading the generally [__]
lifestyle your parents have tried the
whole life stopping you from doing
and worst of all it was cute the signs
of the netherworld were there with her
uncanny ability to transform from cute
girl into crippling midgets and the
promotion of complete anarchy through
the use of drinking coke eating potato
chips and watching shitty anime videos
well [__] Boy Wonder ah of course
with depictions of the perfect grade a
student's living a lazy-ass lifestyle
tormenting her hard-working big brother
into doing whatever she wants in scenes
closely resembling white slavery the
community was split some worship stir
hamster hoodie wearing midgets idolizing
her as the ultimate lifestyle they wish
to live and some detested the hell spawn
of a thing symbolizing the worst part of
their culture getting away with whatever
she wants showing us that cute innocent
girls can secretly be absolute [__] if
they know that no one is watching you
look like a [__] while many see the
show is just another harmless mo a blob
slice of live show which it is it
certainly did succeed in becoming the
fat of the week that everyone loved
hated argued over then immediately
forgot about when the show finished
airing let's hope it stays that way and
no one else takes notice so that the
show doesn't continue to become a
horrible influence to the masses more
than it already has
oh [__] elsewhere in summer season
Dragonball saw the return of overly
muscly men competing in the constipation
Olympics as Toei animation revived the
franchise with Dragon Ball super towaway
were apparently so excited to make a
good sequel they even hired deviantART
to animated episodes resulting in some
of the best fight sequences to ever be
shown that definitely lived up to the
original series shimoneta created a
world where porn and bad language had
been totally banned in a satirical look
at Japanese censorship by creating
modern-day terrorists that spread terror
through use of vulgar pictures swear
words while wearing underpants over
their heads of course of such a
ridiculous concept in this day and age
it does beg the question of what actual
terrorists would look like if they
adopted this policy in the real world Oh
God God [__] God Jun Maeda took everyone
for a wild ride with Charlotte's
following on from the terribly rushed
angel beats he managed to outdo himself
by writing a series that starts off as a
light-hearted version of the x-men which
actually was angel beats miss guys which
actually was dyin skating the skies
which actually was a piece of [__] the
thing ended up so rushed at the climax
of the seasons worth of propagation in a
single episode resulting in such a
[__] of ideas it gave a viewing
experience that essentially felt like
this
the virtual reality gaming trends
continued as overlords all yes not the
poor so trapped in a video game in for
[__] sake so lot online can you [__]
off already the show was the anime
equivalent of the South Park Warcraft
episode that saw a grown man beats on
some helpless children resulting in an
entertaining watch I wouldn't mind
seeing more of of course when the show
is done by madhouse you already owe us
plenty of second seasons you'll reach
the last episode and realised I always
end by setting a plot points for a
second season like yeah yeah you want
this you understand yeah yeah yeah ha ha
and then of course there was prison
school the anime that was a death load
of toilet humor that truly defines what
it means to be a man by far the funniest
animates come out in years
the humor works for having the most
ridiculous situations being played off
the most serious of manners imagine
taking the most overly dramatic scenes
and strategically placing fart noises
everywhere and that's the kind of humor
this show has
if you're into fancy adventurer shows
rockin a yuusha twisted up concept into
a whodunit mystery detective story in
rocker no stuck in a [__] temple for
one bloody season the show spent a whole
season deducting a traitor from a group
of seven that had the entire anime
community playing a giant game of Cluedo
against each other we spilt up to a huge
reveal early to get an ending that put
us right back to square one in a moment
that saw the entire viewership go teeny
Dundas cotton this car this car this
game studio manglobe gave the last
hurrah in gangster in a stylish looking
series that unfortunately was missing
the Polish it needed in the animation
department to stand out well of course
it was monster Musume that managed to
win this year's award for show I really
don't want to explain to my mom in a
series that sees the first year of best
out of all 2050 yes this year to spice
up the competition in a shocking turn of
events human girls were thrown out the
window as audiences could now argue over
which sexy animal they would rather [__]
are you tired of boring predictable
human wife is sick of the constant abuse
the silent treatment or frigid girls who
can't even hold your hand do you want
more than just the boring old ass and
booty why don't you come on down to
monster Musume where we have an animal
to suit your every fetish like bondage
checkup with a snake miss the smell of
unwashed vaginas how about a fish human
girls just go see how the spider instead
legs for days I don't I don't even know
what the [__] this is and for a bonus
I'll even throw in a horse oh oh this is
not what I meant
the good news is even though you know
it's [__] up you'll still get an
erection from watching this show the bad
news is is probably gonna be shaped like
a question mark after the hot Summer Sun
went away people were still waiting for
that one anime to blow them away with a
summer full of animal waifu's plenty of
boobies and the Antichrist in male form
where was the one anime to unite the
community together once again saving
anime and just like that we were
introduced to the world's greatest
one-hit-wonder
every year there seems to be a show -
that goes on to define that year for
future generations
and without a doubt 2015 belonged to the
bald bloke wearing washing-up gloves who
could apparently hit things really hard
yes this year one punch man blasted his
way into anime pop-culture telling the
story of a man who can finish every
fight in one punch
holy [__] half the population gasped
doesn't that get really boring ah okay
how can I put this what the [__] going
on oh my goodness all no the show gains
massive traction as a self-aware parody
of superhero shows poking fun at the
tropes we see ever too often in the show
name Chandra and doing it and well the
jokes always hit and the ever outlandish
blog has an equally entertaining and
ridiculous cast to match we have sexy
mosquitoes shadow the edgehog testicular
cancer colossal Titans some bloke who
got lost on his way in the Tour de
France a better-looking Vin Diesel and a
full robot who just wants to get sensei
to notice him if you also couldn't tell
the action in the show is outstanding
giving us some of the best fight scenes
in recent memory everything about them
has been designed to hype you up - no
err heck listening to the opening alone
gives you enough energy to leap out your
bed drink gallons of red ball and run 10
marathons punching every poor sod you
pass along the way
despite the entire community sucking the
show's dick and hyping it up to high
heaven it's one of the few shows that
mostly deserves the hyper guest so I
highly recommend you check it out unless
you're one of those people that hate
anything that's popular I know like
punch man is the most overhyped web show
ever
do you think this is a masterpiece then
you clearly have no taste it should go
back to watching Naruto
sokka elsewhere in the fall season
beautiful bones gave us an interesting
detective anime that partly felt like a
combination of Sherlock and bones by far
the highlight of the show was Sakurako
the distant sociopathic necrophiliac
detective who happens to be really cute
and also has an unhealthy obsession with
bones attack on titan got its own parody
spin-off in dankmemes the anime based on
a manga that took all the used attack on
titan jokes found on the internet and
attempting to make an entire show around
it this year was also a historic year as
Obama himself thanks Japan for anime and
manga while anime thanked Obama by
showing scenes of him figuring out how
to solve the economic crisis in those
Tomatsu Saad thank you for all the
things we loved from Japan anime yes was
so much a sign was a great comedy anime
that went to largely unnoticed as it was
a revival the nineteen sixties anime
that no one has really heard about the
Gundam franchise gave us another outing
of blood orphans telling yet another
story around the politics and horrors of
wars with giant robots smashing the [__]
out of each other in between this
version included a more gritty edgy tone
in contrast other series and normally
sees the unfair strategy of using
overpowered gunmen to spam laser beams
in every conceivable direction causing
the average lifespan of a none Gundam
pilot to equate to about point one was
second Saturday morning cartoons
returned to our screens briefly a
Digimon Adventure tri gave us a
nostalgia boner we so aptly deserved as
the kids we knew and loved are now all
grown up I mean Luke is Digimon Digimon
Digimon
Matt time your de not to have gay
dojinshi about you now me me you no
longer have a starfish forehead Sora
you're still leading the guys on you
can't teasing [__] and TK you've grown
up to become a fedora wearing scrublord
what the [__] went wrong with you if you
are ever feeling unfit and unmotivated
then Anatol eggs provided an alternative
to those late-night Fitness infomercials
that call you a fat sod because you're
too stupid to figure out how to do
sit-ups correctly alright this time I go
ah almost possible like slow-mo anymore
unfortunately what the producers didn't
realize is that most people can't
exercise and masturbate at the same time
the Naruto franchise released another
movie in Beirut oh the movie following
their previous release of Narita the
last movie I don't know your definition
of last is in the route oh but I think
dictionary.com has to disagree and
finally dragonball resurrection death
saw the return a freezer to give us this
isn't even my final form the movie
yes freezers come up from the dead this
songs blow up earth and a fight to the
death taking place during a whopping
five minutes stretched over three movies
50 episodes and 20 hours worth powering
up oh we get seen you Super Saiyan form
that's right
Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan square to
the power of seven Super Saiyan over
cubed root Super Saiyan minus 2 Super
Saiyan and of course that sums up the
entire year the year that gave us more
string boobs more tentacle rape more
people dying when they're killed last
[__] team more dankmemes more
varma more gate vampires more higher
heat season 3 never more food with born
more born with food more lesbian ships
more giant robots more clue days more
[__] bags more Sherlock bones more
Pokemon more studio triggered more jinn
my Eider more questionable boners with
more arguments over asked all kiddies
more use underwear more unlikely couples
Warner York ordered a little over more
staying alive more sawed off and line
more final forms more people putting
their hands up and of course more zero
[__] given man I've been Giga doubles
out of me in 2015 and now now ready to
go down because life part two is now
children then genie gonna do soon evil
I don't even know what to say anymore I
guess I'm sorry I didn't get this video
out when I said I would no one has ever
done that hey guys it's gig okay I hope
you enjoyed that video if you're
interested in any of the anime I talked
about in that video and then I put a
list in the description below most of
them are also available on crunchyroll
so you can go to crunchyroll.com such
enemies own for a free month of premium
membership so yeah they're real update
for me this time I'm still alive and
kicking but I do have a big announcement
in the coming months so until then I've
been gig up I'll see you guys next time